so apple has brought out a few different
macbook pros
and macbook airs this year today we're
going to be talking about
which one is best for you
what's going on guys my name is david
tomic and welcome back to the channel
today we're looking at the variety of
apple macbook products
that have recently come out in 2020
we're going to be discussing the apple
macbook air
the two versions of the macbook pro 13
inch model and the 16 inch macbook pro
so i want to make this video very short
sharp and sweet i don't want to
overwhelm you with facts and figures
so we're going to run through this very
quickly make sure you pay attention
if you're looking at buying the macbook
air i suggest that you stick to this
category if you're somebody
that's planning on using this device for
typing
reading and writing and some very
generic web browsing
if you're a student looking for a
lightweight compact
cheapest apple laptop on the market this
is the one for you
if you're looking at doing a little bit
more labor-intensive exercises
even if it's still just watching netflix
and
browsing the internet but want something
that is definitely going to last you
that little bit longer
well the macbook pro for only 100 grams
more and a couple hundred dollars more
is definitely worth the upgrade if you
have the extra money and you're debating
these two
it isn't a debate just go with the
13-inch macbook pro
now as you probably know there's two
versions of this bad boy here
there is the 13-inch macbook pro with
two usbc ports
and there's a 13-inch macbook pro with
four usb-c
ports now there's a number of
differences in these ports including the
8th gen chip
and the 10th gen chip basically what you
really need to know here is
are you somebody that's looking at doing
some graphic intensive
exercises for example are you using
architectural programs
are you playing video games are you
doing anything
that is peaking outside of the absolute
maximum of some very basic photoshop
requirements
if the answer is no there's no point you
going out and wasting
an extra couple hundred dollars on the
10th generation model
over the eighth generation the 10th
generation
macbook pro 13 13-inch model with four
usb c ports
is definitely targeted at those who are
looking
to really drive the graphics power of
the computer
it isn't the best gaming computer on the
market but it can hold its own
so if you're looking to play a couple
games do some graphics intensive
exercises
maybe render out a few different models
and
potentially potentially
even do some very very serious
photoshopping and rendering
this is the option you should be looking
at the macbook air won't be able to do
any of these things the 13-inch macbook
pro with the 8th generation chip
will be able to do only some of these
things but the 10th generation
intel chip in the 13 inch model will be
your go-to for sure
and finally if you're looking at the
16-inch
macbook pro well you know what you're
looking at you know exactly what you
need
the 16-inch macbook pro comes in at 3799
australian dollars it is one of the most
expensive macbook pros on the market and
that's
just the intro model the only time i'd
recommend going up to the 16 inch
macbook pro
if you aren't already a serious power
user is if you're already comparing
the previous macbook models and looking
to upgrade the specs in them
once you upgrade the 13-inch macbook pro
specs
even ever so slightly you end up in the
16 inch macbook terrain
don't be fooled though the 16 inch
macbook pro is very
very heavy if you're looking to use this
as a replacement for your desktop
that's exactly what it's going to be but
if you're looking to use it as a student
computer
carrying it around on campus that is not
the computer for you i didn't want to
overwhelm you with facts and figures i
didn't want to overwhelm you with specs
if you're looking to buy a macbook for
whatever reason it is
you know what you need this is just
really a confirmation
telling you if you're a student very
basic macbook air
a student with a little bit more of a
requirement for their computer
macbook pro 8th generation intel chip
a student looking at graphics intensive
courses
10th gen chip 13 inch model and a
student
looking to replace their desktop who
really needs
a high-end graphics computer the 16-inch
model
anyway that's all from me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button 20 20 style
and as always i'll see you next monday